[Aplausos]
vocês sabiam que até a década de 70
apenas 6 por cento da totalidade dos
músicos que atuavam nas orquestras
sinfônicas dos estados unidos eram
mulheres
muitos julgavam que a capacidade
intelectual das mulheres era menor mas
de repente algumas coisas começam a
acontecer que vão mudar completamente
esse cenário algumas orquestras
americanas decidem mudar o sistema de
avaliação dos candidatos
e aí começam então a serem organizadas
as audições às cegas que foram
implantadas por algumas orquestras
americanas depois de 20 anos
e notem apenas algumas orquestras
americanas fizeram isso não chegamos a
década de 90 com um cenário da música
erudita nos estados unidos completamente
diferente aquele triste deprimente
número de seis por cento tinha mudado
completamente o número era outro nós
tínhamos chegado a 20 1%
e essa mudança tinha sido operada por
conta de uma modificação de um mecanismo
que neutralizar a o pré conceito de
fundo o sexual
agora vou pedir pra vocês guardar na
memória essa história e esses números
nós vamos precisar dela daqui a pouco
nós vamos mudar de país
eu vou convidá-los a me acompanhar em de
volta para o brasil em 1980 em são paulo
a sociedade civil pressionava as
instituições paulistas para que
finalmente se dignassem admitir a
participação de mulheres nos concursos
públicos para a magistratura estadual
pasmem há 36 anos as mulheres ainda não
participavam nas carreiras da
magistratura a pressão foi grande
o tribunal de justiça de são paulo
finalmente admite
a presença de mulheres e as mulheres
começam finalmente a participar dos
processos de seleção das carreiras de
juiz mas a situação dessas mulheres era
muito difícil e elas não conseguiam ter
uma performance muito boa a cada
concurso um pouco mais um pouco menos
apenas duas e 15% das vagas eram
ocupadas por mulheres
bonitão um fenômeno um bombástico
acontece
o tribunal de justiça do estado de são
paulo é impedido de exibir o gênero dos
candidatos fica proibida a identificação
dos candidatos por ocasião dos concursos
os candidatos passam então fazer as
provas sobre um número sem nome o que
acontece
o resultado é bombástico o número de
mulheres salta para 40% no primeiro
concurso que acontece logo depois da
implantação da mudança
depois que a regra de identificação dos
candidatos é alterada quase se
equiparando com a performance masculina
é evidente essa situação não deixa
dúvidas assim como a das musicistas
americanas não deixava que as mãos é as
mulheres estavam sendo barradas
o resultado dessas provas e desses
concursos parecia meritocrático
mas será que ele era mérito crítico
parece evidente que não as mulheres
musicista as americanas e as mulheres
candidatas a carreira de juíza em são
paulo dois países diferentes momentos
paralelos são então capazes e só porque
estes mecanismos foram introduzidos de
acessarem as carreiras
portanto quando nós lidamos com o
conceito de meritocracia
nós temos que tomar muito cuidado porque
a meritocracia só é mérito cra cia e ela
só existe forte pujante
se o ponto de partida foi igual para
homens
mulheres quando o gênero não for o
critério dominante de partida
se isto não acontece nós não estamos
falando de meritocracia
nós estamos falando de fundamentalismo
de gênero e é por isso que a carreira
das mulheres é tão complexa e é tão
difícil para as mulheres
ocorre que as mulheres que queiram estar
nas ciências que queiram gerir empresas
terão que saltar exatamente os mesmos
obstáculos e mais alguns são os
obstáculos do preconceito os obstáculos
do sexismo e nesse exato momento a
meritocracia está rompida ela não existe
mais e pior porque se a mulher for negra
aí então é que ela jamais poderá almejar
um cargo de liderança nesse país
os obstáculos que nós temos que superar
não são apenas os obstáculos de tui
performance ligados àquela actividade
profissional são obstáculos culturais e
contra os obstáculos culturais
é muito difícil o combate os obstáculos
culturais têm que ser derrubados
pra isso vários países descobriram já há
bastante tempo que são necessárias ações
afirmativas não basta conversar
não basta passar leis é absolutamente
imperioso abrir espaço mérito cra
ticamente para aquelas pessoas que a
despeito de terem estudado muito de
trabalhar em tanto quanto por mais que
façam e façam não chegaram lá não fossem
os mecanismos que tinham sido
introduzidos estas mulheres jamais
teriam chegado lá
o quadro que vocês estão vendo acaba de
ser publicado há poucos dias mensurados
pelos parâmetros do fórum econômico
mundial
os 10 melhores para países em termos de
de igualdade de gênero
o que de peculiar este conjunto de
países tem é que os primeiros colocados
neste ranking não estão aí à toa
quais são esses países islândia em
primeiro lugar a finlândia a noruega a
suécia que países são esses são os
países nórdicos que há alguns anos
aliás há muitos anos há décadas
implantaram políticas e ações
afirmativas são medidas governamentais
variadas espécies que permitem que
corrija se a deficiência de mérito
crates de meritocracia a partida mas
também na continuação do processo porque
não adianta corrigir a entrada e não
manter a correção ao longo da caminhada
76 por cento de todas de dos diretores
executivos hoje em atuação no país
apenas 76 por cento são mulheres e
mulheres brancas a participação da
mulher negra nos cargos de cúpula da
direção executiva das grandes empresas
no brasil é tão pequena que ela
estatisticamente relevante
vejam o número é um número bem triste
é um número semelhante àquele número das
músicas americanas não é mesmo
estes países que vocês estão vendo
nesses quadros estabeleceram ações
afirmativas de diversas mas
prioritariamente a cota de gênero
a cota de gênero fez com que esses
países fossem pra as mensurações
variadas lá pra cima pra frente porque
sabem há muito tempo que é muito
importante ter em mulheres em cargos de
comando em níveis equivalentes aos
homens nunca foi a pretensão no
feminismo que fossemos mais o que
tivéssemos mais sempre foi a pretensão
do feminismo que nós tivéssemos as
mesmas oportunidades igualdade de
tratamento
eu não tenho nada contra homens como
nenhuma feminista tem mas o que eu tenho
a favor e eu tenho muito a favor é das
mulheres porque não é justo barrar a
capacidade intelectual
um ser humano só porque ele tem um sexo
ou outro ou porque ele é preto ou branco
o porquê ele amarelo ou roxo
quando nós temos uma verdadeira
meritocracia o melhor vai se destacar e
o melhor é aquele que merece por isso
mérito é aquele que tem estudado mais
que tenha se dedicado mais porque não há
democracia quando 51.5 por cento da
população de um país estão fora
completamente fora dos espaços de
decisão nós mulheres não participamos do
legislativo na sua cúpula
nós mulheres brasileiras não
participamos do judiciário na sua cúpula
a correção feita pelo tribunal de
justiça pelos outros foi na entrada da
carreira da magistratura mas não
acompanha as mulheres vão evoluir na
carreira
vejam esse gráfico a linha amarela bege
representa o desempenho das companhias
que têm nos seus conselhos de
administração uma ou mais mulheres a
linha roxa representa as companhias que
não tem nenhuma mulher no seu conselho
de administração e o que é o conselho de
administração é a cúpula decisória das
grandes companhias no brasil a nossa
presença nos conselhos de administração
das grandes companhias é pífia ao
entorno de 7.8 por cento e por que é
importante que nós estivéssemos lá
porque são os conselhos de administração
que tomam decisões relevantes 'mas pro
futuro dessas empresas são os conselhos
de administração por exemplo que
escolhem os diretores executivos
lembram se quando eu disse a vocês que
hoje no brasil apenas 7 pontos 5 por
cento das diretorias executivas do país
são ocupadas por mulheres
então o conselho de administração escola
de leitores com a executiva o conselho
de administração estabelece princípios
metodologias que são relevantes para
desenvolver os negócios da companhia e
se nós estamos nos conselhos de
administração nós podemos cuidar não só
para que as mulheres entrem nessas
companhias em igualdade de condições mas
também para que essas mulheres possam
continuar o seu percurso profissional
sem ter que desistir
no meio do caminho podendo almejar de
forma real que se ela trabalhar se ela
se esforçar se ela tiver mérito ela
chegará lá
este gráfico mostra que as mulheres que
é quando as mulheres participam na
cúpula de gestão a companhia tem a
possibilidade de ter até 40% a mais de
resultado
o próximo gráfico revela números ainda
mais acachapante es
o primeiro gráfico de vocês vêem nos
mostram que companhias que têm uma ou
mais mulheres em sua cúpula tem 10% a
mais de holten um ebit 48% maior e suas
ações são valorizados nas bolsas de
valores em média 17% a mais manter as
mulheres fora da cúpula é além de tudo
burrice
gera-se - valor no país não se ganha
tanto dinheiro com tributos mantém-se
uma população ativa com capacidade e
potência equivalente à dos homens
fora do mercado de trabalho e o país
definitivamente perde riqueza pede
justiça e perde qualidade democrática
o próximo gráfico recentíssimo também
nos mostra a quantidade de mulheres
participando nos conselhos de
administração em todo o mundo notem quem
são os primeiros colocados de novo o
nosso clube nórdico os países lá de cima
que muito inteligentemente já perceberam
isso faz tempo e que estabeleceram cotas
para mulheres nos seus conselhos de
administração entre outras ações
afirmativas como por exemplo a licença
paternidade mandatória porque para as
crianças é tão importante ter a mãe do
seu lado quanto também é ter o pai do
seu lado porque da mesma forma que vocês
têm direito a nós também temos direito a
direito a ser mãe direito a ser pai
direito a ser presidente de uma
companhia direito também de ser
nós mulheres presidente de uma companhia
direito de presidir um conselho de
administração que vai interferir
positivamente numa produção mais efetiva
na geração de maiores empregos na
agregação de maior valor - corrupção sim
os índices estatísticos mundiais
comprovadamente mostram que as mulheres
são menos afetadas pelo bichinho que
leva à corrupção
este quadro com para três países
olha que interessante as primeiras
linhas revelam riqueza dinheiro
nós estamos falando de índice de
desenvolvimento humano estamos falando
de renda per capta
vamos focar nesses dois itens o índice
de desenvolvimento humano é tão alto na
noruega que ela ocupa o primeiro lugar
no mundo a alemanha em sexto
já nós em 75º lugar segundo item a renda
per capta a noruega e em quinto lugar
a alemanha em 19º eo brasil 64º próximo
item a o número de mulheres participando
no legislativo aquele poder que faz as
leis que impõe comportamentos que
estabelece políticas públicas que no
caso da noruega
a quantidade de mulheres a coloca em 15º
lugar na alemanha 26º eo brasil em pior
ainda 155º lugar
aliás eu não sei se vocês sabem mas nós
temos menos mulheres no parlamento no
poder legislativo no espaço político do
que a maioria esmagadora dos países
nórdicos nós perdemos para a arábia
saudita
sou o iêmen ganha da gente lá na américa
nós perdemos de todos só ganhamos do
haiti mas notem que tem uma linha aí que
nos coloca lado a lado com alguém
a alemanha neste momento está mais
próxima do brasil não está só porque a
alemanha não tinha
notas para mulheres até o ano passado
contra a noruega que as tenha 20 anos
o que nós queremos é equilíbrio o que
nós queremos é respeito e eu decidi que
eu vou morrer lutando eu não virei mais
não sei se a minha filha verá mas ela
vai ter a certeza de que eu continuo
lutando por ela e eu continuo lutando
por todas vocês que estão aqui mas
também pelos homens porque vai fazer bem
pra vocês compartilhar e aproveitando um
monte de se pede
já era tempo já era tempo de o anão
abrir mais o jornal e descobrir naquele
dia que o governador do estado de são
paulo será composto o seu gabinete de
secretários estaduais e dentre os 26 só
duas eram mulheres
já era tempo de não ter quem luta tanto
já era tempo de que as cotas estivessem
funcionando no brasil porque nós
precisamos de cota de gênero ti os
nórdicos precisaram com tanta riqueza
mais porque é que nós não precisaríamos
já era tempo de que eu não tivesse que
abrir o jornal e descobrir que um
presidente da república ou usar a nomear
22 ministros em que uma única desses
ministros possível
[Aplausos]
já era tempo que nós pudéssemos olhar os
nossos queridos homens com respeito e um
carinho e que eles assim mas olhassem
também já era tempo da mulher não ter
que estar só em casa
já era tempo da mulher poder ir à praça
pública sem ser violentada sem ser
desprezada sendo respeitada
eu continuo lutando ea minha única
alegria é que o morro lutando muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]